there's one really common
nutritional deficiency behind
constipation i want to share with you
today this is actually very very
interesting and it makes a lot of sense
once you get all the information
i want to start here with a couple facts
there are more nerves in your gut than
there are in your spinal column
you also have a very long nerve called
the vagus nerve that goes between your
brain
and your gut and is bidirectional which
means it goes up and down it carries
information back and forth now the vagus
nerve is connected to
the lower part of the brain called the
brain stem and in that brain stem
you have the
core of something called the autonomic
nervous system the system that runs on
automatic okay now many times people
think there's just two parts to that you
have the sympathetic nervous system and
the parasympathetic but you have
actually a third part it's called the
entire and so that is called the second
brain and it innervates the entire gut
and it's all nerve tissue and the reason
i'm telling you that is this
the brain stem or shall i say the
autonomic nervous system is very
vulnerable
to
thymine deficiencies that's vitamin b1
deficiencies when you don't have enough
thymine
all sorts of things go
wacko with the autonomic nervous system
and this especially rates to anything
nerve okay like the nerve innervation to
the smooth muscle in your gut which
controls something called peristalsis i
mean if you think about what
constipation really is it's a
lack of peristalsis the peristalsis is
not working you're not pumping
uh waste through the body and so it's
stagnant it's not in motion
if you've ever heard of a severe b1
deficiency it's called
beriberi
but there's a part of beriberi called
gastrointestinal
berry berry which involves the blocking
of peristalsis
your intestines just don't pump anymore
so things just kind of sit there and so
this occurs because there is a b1
deficiency that is in the brain stem
that controls
all these nerves from above
the brainstem and especially the
autonomic nervous system depend on
getting enough b1 and so when they don't
have enough
the vagus nerve cannot use acetylcholine
to allow this to occur and so
acetylcholine is like a hormone within
your nervous system okay it depends on
vitamin b1 you see you normally you're
supposed to eat food you have all this
acid in the stomachs breaking down the
protein
creating an environment which kills
pathogens okay the absorption of certain
uh minerals and the food comes down this
little pipe right here and you have this
little sac called the gallbladder that
secretes a bile that helps you start
breaking down the fats with the help of
the pancreas and the pancreas also
releases additional enzymes to break
down this food stuff right here and then
you have the small intestine right here
and 90 of all the digestion occurs in
the small intestine right and then it
empties into the large intestine where
you have
more digestion and fermentation of
things that are not digested or we don't
have the capacity to digest like fiber
and then it comes out through here and
so when people have constipation we have
a backup of this whole system and so so
people will start taking probiotics
they'll start taking
betaine hydrochloride they'll take
purified bile salts they'll take enzymes
and sometimes they depend on either
medication like laxatives or even herbal
laxatives which are much better but when
you have to keep taking something over
and over and over
it's obvious that you haven't found the
right problem and i'm not against taking
laxatives if they're herbal as long as
you at the same time try to correct
what's really going on
because the danger of constipation is
greater than the danger of taking
laxatives because it's called
auto-intoxication where the waste just
sits there okay it just sits there it
doesn't go through the body and it can
back up and create a lot of toxicity
not only does a thymine deficiency
cause this peristalsis problem but the
thymine deficiency also inhibits
hcl in the stomach it inhibits your
stomach acid okay the stuff that you
need to break down protein so if you
have undigested protein that alone can
cause constipation
you need this acid to also kill
microbes so you don't develop
microbes in the wrong place like in your
small intestine which is called small
intestinal bacterial overgrowth which
comes from a lack of hydrochloric acid
so that's an interesting connection
low vitamin b1 thymine also inhibits
gastric motility talking about the
motility of your stomach
not just the intestines but the stomach
mobility too
and so a version of that condition is
called
gastroparesis where everything is kind
of just really sluggish going through
the digestive system and i've done a
video on gastroparesis before which
basically is this slowing down of your
digestion
being caused
by diabetes because diabetes involves
high level of carbohydrates and sugar
which is one of the primary causes of a
b1 deficiency refine carbohydrates or
refined
sugar
as in the breads the pasta the cereal
the crackers the biscuits the pancakes
etc so you eat a lot of carbohydrates
you get diabetes you create a b1
deficiency and then you get
gastroparesis not to mention a lot of
other problems with the nervous system
but this is a side note by diabetics
typically get peripheral neuropathy the
bottom of their feet
becomes numb burning
painful because of a lack of b1 b1
deficiency affects the nervous system at
many different levels and so what we're
talking about here is the relationship
and connection between a b1 deficiency
and your autonomic nervous system which
originates in the brain stem but extends
out to the vagus nerve and into the
enteric nervous system now a b1
deficiency can also inhibit
pancreatic enzymes okay so now we can't
release the enzymes to digest
of your digestion occurs in the small
intestine with a lot of help from that
pancreas right here
also a b1 deficiency like i just said
causes gastroparesis
and another condition which i'm going to
define
bilirary
dyskinesia now what is biliary
dyskinesia
that is simply
a sluggish gallbladder
the gallbladder should contract and
release bile
but with this condition it doesn't it's
sluggish okay so we're not talking about
a lack of bile we're just talking about
the muscular the soft tissue that's
supposed to be contracting and releasing
the bile well you're going to actually
have less bile to help you digest and
that all comes from a b1
deficiency so
as you can see the common thread behind
constipation is a lack of thymine now if
you're going to take a thymine remedy b1
remedy i would highly recommend you find
one
that is natural not synthetic
now since we're on the topic of b1
there's a lot more to know about it's a
fascinating vitamin
you should check out this video i did
at my one of my summits i'll put it up
right here check it out
you